for ufo researchers like chris jones
one place symbolizes decades of
government secrecy
we're standing in front of the back gate
for
uh area 51 out here in the middle of the
nevada desert
where uh many believe that uh reverse
engineered uh extraterrestrial craft
were also
tested and stationed in this base this
would be ground
zero for activity regarding uh
the us government's involvement in
the phenomenon and the technology
the secrets of area 51 are likely to
remain just that
but the u s government is at last
beginning to answer questions about what
it knows
and what it doesn't the ufo community in
general feels that
uh the government's acknowledgment of
the phenomenon
is a validation of years of their
efforts to
disclose what's going on yes
there's something out there no we don't
know what it is but it's worth looking
into
well it's rotated
the us government admits it can't say
whether these are
extraterrestrials or not the one known
as the tic-tac
was filmed by a u.s navy crew one of
them
says national security is just one
concern
i feel that i was pulling something out
of the future in in some way that
there was an echo about this this was
not just another
flock of birds or a balloon or a
or swamp gas we knew that this was a
craft that was outstripping our arsenal
and that was in 2004
so i did feel it was historical then now
i'm positive of that fact
but i think that there's even more out
there that we need to we need to see and
understand
but those who've been to space say a
man-made explanation
is still more likely the government has
said that
there's no evidence that these are alien
spacecraft and i still don't believe
they are
and i still believe we've been visited
by alien spacecraft simply because
although
i think there's life elsewhere in the
universe the distances are so vast that
i don't think we'll ever find each other
but the man who fought for greater
government openness
says there's no going back now this goes
back some 70 years
we know initially the government did
everything we could to cover it up
i think that the new technology we have
has made it more difficult for
government to deny what's going on and
the government's got to be part of they
can no longer be
part of a cover-up they've got to be
transparent in everything they do
in the desert stand the landmarks to an
enduring fascination
attractions for those curious for
answers
in the area 51 postbox they leave
messages
and popcorn for any alien visitors will
we ever know for sure
if they have been contacting us greg
milam sky news nevada